[Music]
a person who's cheated in the past can
change
some people cheat to avoid relationship
issues
54.5 percent of couples break up due to
an admission of cheating
sometimes people cheat even when they're
happy
[Music]
47 of people who admit infidelity feel
guilty
only one in five relationships end
because of cheating
[Music]
people who cheat tend to minimize their
behavior
some people cheat when they lack
self-respect
infidelity is responsible for 20 to 40
percent of divorces in America
on the other hand sexual desires not
being met could be a reason for
infidelity
[Music]
67.4 percent of married people regret
cheating
a need for variety could be a reason for
cheating
reasons for cheating could be
situational
[Music]
women are more likely to cheat for
emotional reasons
[Music]
a Jeter can still love their primary
partner
[Music]
cheating is an individual thing everyone
experiences it differently
[Music]
a cheater may be motivated by lack of
love
[Music]
you could still be cheated on even if
you have a great sex life
[Music]
men and women May view infidelity
differently
[Music]
46 percent of people confess to cheating
[Music]
women are less likely to cheat if they
report being in a happy relationship
those who have confessed to cheating may
have had ulterior motives
people who cheat sometimes have low
self-esteem
some people cheat because it adds
excitement to their lives
people who've cheated report doing so
because they felt neglected by their
partners
some men actually cheat to save their
marriages
[Music]
successful women are 1.5 times more
likely to cheat on their Partners than
lower earning women
are less likely to cheat especially if
the reason is sexual attraction
[Music]
the percentage of relationships that
work after cheating is very small only
16 percent
[Music]
more than half of men and women have
cheated on their partner at some point
in their lives
[Music]
people that are economically dependent
on their spouses are more likely to have
affairs
[Music]
beans May influence the likelihood of
cheating thank you
men who cheat are more likely to suffer
sudden coital death
[Music]
women are capable of both sexual
cheating and emotional cheating
the cuddle hormone can prevent cheating
[Music]
people over 55 are more likely to cheat
[Music]
cheating happens most frequently when a
person is drunk or on drugs
[Music]
being emotionally immature is the root
of white people cheat
women have a harder time with monogamy
than men do
[Music]
morality is the main factor preventing
married people from cheating
[Music]
the saddest part of a cheater's
personality is that they often carry
emotional scars from their past
[Music]
faking orgasms can lead to infidelity
[Music]
cheaters may become more sexually active
in their relationships
[Music]
a partner's infidelity can sometimes end
a relationship but not always
[Music]
working through infidelity can
strengthen our relationship
we feel differently based on the sex of
the person our partner cheats with
can make you stronger
[Music]
the incidence of cheating has been level
for the past 20 years
[Music]
men are more likely to cheat when they
have a milestone birthday coming up
[Music]
younger people are now less likely to
cheat than older people
cheating can be a sign of deep
relational issues
women cheat more often while ovulating
social media has led to more cheating
[Music]
happens in 65 percent of marriages
people usually cheat on someone in their
friend's Circle
people who cheat prefer an emotional
roller coaster over emotional stability
[Music]
high IQ people are more likely to cheat
[Music]
women under 25 are more likely to cheat
people with low oxytocin and vasopressin
are more likely to cheat
[Music]
women cheat in order to end the
relationship
[Music]
infidelity can happen as soon as two
years into a marriage
[Music]
people who pretend that everything is
good are likely to cheat
women fear that men with deep voices are
more likely to cheat
a man who works in finance is more
likely to cheat as is a woman in
education
[Music]
cheating women spend twice as much as
non-cheaters while shopping
[Music]
eating men are more likely to suffer
from heart attacks
cheating can be regarded as an outlet
for frustration
85 percent of affairs start in the
workplace
[Music]
you are more likely to have an affair
before a new decade of life
foreign
physical traits and characteristics are
linked to infidelity
[Music]
age matters in cheating couples
[Music]
cheating is a form of control
[Music]
cheating is often an outlet for
frustration and unsolved troubles in a
relationship
if the deceit is likely to be exposed it
becomes less attractive and is less
likely to be attempted
foreign
[Music]